[Music]
all right thank you so much sam
um shannon and i are going to be talking
a little bit about the thematic and
bootstrap lid package today
uh in short these are new packages to
theme shiny as well as our markdown
and traditional web content and we're
really excited about kind of the
breadth of what this can do for theming
and kind of the ease of use to get
started
so first off uh introducing these
packages
bootstrap lib or what we're calling
bslib is really just simplified theming
of web content via bootstrap
now web content meaning could be shiny
could be our markdown
and you know bootstrap as well as for
traditional web pages so
there's a lot of power there thematic on
the other hand is
kind of a complementary package to bslib
which is simplified theming of r plots
meaning ggplot
lattice base and plotly that is kind of
works in conjunction with bslib
both of these have package down websites
where you can find out a lot more info
about them
thematic is on crayon already um and
blueshardlib is kind of waiting in the
crayon queue so it should hopefully be
the next few days um if you want to get
started with them today
you can always install the dev versions
from github as you see here with this
code
and a big thanks to carson seaver let me
adapt some of his slides for today's
presentation
he's one of the core devs working on
both bootstrap live and thematic as part
of our shiny team
so first off for some folks you may have
been using shiny before
you may have been using our markdown
before but less people are kind of aware
using bootstrap natively and what this
is is really just
a lot of css and javascript plugins for
front-end web development
you can dive deeper into bootstrap and
we're gonna have a great presentation
about sas
which is kind of using these variables
right after this presentation
but in short this is kind of working
behind the scenes in bslib and other
packages
and kind of provides you all these nice
fees without you having to know about it
so bootstrap lib is a wrapper around
custom bootstrap themes and makes it
really easy
to theme your documents and use things
like sas variables without having to
write all this custom css
out of the box now if you do know those
skills and if you gain those skills from
someone like absalon or have them
working with you
they can further extend your
applications with css or sas variables
but again this is really kind of a r
interface and functions
where you don't have to know all of it
to get started
and again you've been using components
of this through shining our mark down
for years you just probably didn't know
it
so to start using bslib it's really just
a one function
call so we have a very basic shiny app
here for the ui component and then we're
also going to load the bs lib package
so we could call fluid page although it
could really be any component of shiny
and this theme argument will take bs
underscore theme
as the argument so this will provide
kind of an interface to bs lib and all
the different theming components you
could do
like background foreground fonts
changing all these different components
in bulk on the page without having to
write individual css for each item
so fluid page navbar page bootstrap page
all these different things have the same
kind of theme
equals bs theme argument and again you
may have been using
this theme argument something like shiny
themes or writing your own custom
bootstrap css
bootstrap theme is more powerful kind of
in our minds because you are providing
you know against sas variables
all the niceties of bootstrap in there
again
either the power or the ease of use kind
of both balanced together
now something to note here is that uh
for bootstrap
users this is moving from bootstrap 3 to
bootstrap 4 which is a more modern
more recent implementation of bootstrap
so
there is some compatibility layers here
that should help most shiny apps just
work out of the box and upgrade to
bootstrap 4.
however if you have some legacy
applications you could always try
version equals 3 here in the bs theme
argument
if it is kind of messing with you with
your overall theme
but for new applications just stick to
bootstrap 4 it's again
a more recent version and that'll be the
good recommendation
you know in terms of what bootstrap 3
versus bootstrap 4 looks like
really it's hard to tell the difference
you might see it here
in terms of like this blue is so
slightly lighter the fonts are a little
bit different maybe not as bold
really most of the benefits are behind
the scenes like just switching from
version to three to four
might give you this more slightly modern
looking feel
um but it's not going to change you know
the core of your application
just with the the base theme but there
are again lots of things built in there
that
it's worth upgrading before
to preview a theme and actually get into
some of the bulk of what
uh these themes can do for you uh you
can call this new function from bslib
bs underscore theme underscore preview
and this will take bs theme as an
argument
and you can provide either custom themes
that you've built yourself
or full boot swatch themes which are
essentially open source
free themes that other people have
created so you can see with essentially
one line of code we've taken this basic
shiny application and themed every
component of it
so the fonts are different this is
perpetuated into all the drop downs so
the date
the select input state ranges the slider
bars
all those will respect the right colors
the right fonts
uh and other components that you're
changing as well as the kind of
pop-ups or action buttons so primary
secondary warnings danger buttons
accent colors again all of this is
changing
kind of in bulk and together in a
unified interface
so if you want to just use one of these
boot swatch themes out of the box
they're going to be very powerful
and should be very pretty a lot of them
have been kind of used for front end
development for years
but you can also kind of customize a
wide portion of your wrap
with things like sass variables or other
functions built into bootstrap
so again well i've kind of hit on this a
couple times i really want to protect
people in terms of
don't be scared if there's things in
here that you haven't seen before
if you want to learn those you'll be
even more powerful but they're not
necessary
to use it so if you did want to dive
deeper into sas
again there's going to be a presentation
right after this about it and there is
some documentation about the sas r
wrapper
for you know r packages that will let
you kind of learn how to use those
in in short i'm not going to read this
whole thing but sas is really a meta
language on top of css
so if you think of css as changing
individual components
sas would kind of provide a more elegant
or systematic syntax letting you change
multiple things at one time
this usually leads to more manageable
style sheets or styling in general
so i mentioned earlier that you can
create your own theme so we showed a
pre-built bootswatch theme
now we're using essentially the same
argument so bootstrap theme
but we're uh kind of mandating what
specific components we want to change
so again this theme may not be the most
pretty thing to you i kind of made it a
little bit garish just to pop
out but you can see the background is
gray the foreground is black so we have
a
you know background of gray and then the
font will be in black
the primary color is this lovely purple
which goes along with our ladies and i
really do like it
maybe not with this gray theme and then
we change the base font to francis which
is kind of again a very different font
and you can see that the font is
perpetuated into each of the different
sections
so yeah i don't really love frances as a
theme or as a font but you can see that
each of the different parts
are changing which is the part to
highlight here
you might also notice that i didn't have
to load externally
a different font i just said you know
pull in this google font
process and i can change it to anything
i want and it will automatically pull in
the style css and the google font
download it and load it in your
application
so making it really easy to import
google fonts and there's
hundreds of different ones you could use
here as well as the most common ones
used in web dev
if we switch over to probably a better
palette in terms of not one i created
randomly but one that's based off
something like material dark
you can again see that we've changed all
the components at once so the
backgrounds change
the foreground is still this lovely
purple um and then we have a new font
this time fiera sands which is one font
that i actually really do like
and again it's perpetuating this into
the sliders into all the different
components
all at once and with minimal code i'm
able to create a robustly themed
application
we'll go over a demo of like what all
these different things are
in short like this screenshot shows you
the bulk of it but you can use
uh bootstrap preview with this to like
show what plots would look like what
tables would look like notifications
different fonts and you can actually
customize it
live inside the shiny application which
is really cool
and so i will show you that right now in
terms of
what the preview looks like let me pull
this over here
so if i again i'm inside our studio
i'm just going to pull up this code
chunk i have here so bootstrap theme
preview
and then providing it with some
arguments to the bootstrap theme
component
so if i run this it'll load the shiny
application
i'll make that full screen give it a
second to spin
up and now here is my kind of matrix
themed
shiny application so again all the
different buttons work and i can change
things like the font so maybe i don't
want firomano and i want lotto
i can close that out and it will change
the fonts
i can go to accent colors and say well i
don't want the primary color to be
green let's do f-zero f-zero f-zero
we'll make it
like a white background or primary color
and now everything's here in white
i can go over to plots and do
let it load for a second my cpu is
getting some pressure from the uh
from the web screen or webcasting
so the the plots here are perpetuated
and have those themed as well
the tables are themed to match the
background
notifications all these different things
so
again as you're kind of playing around
with different themes and want to change
them
you have this ability to see what all
the different components of an
application
look like without having to write all
this different code just to test it
you could obviously like you know run up
your actual production application
locally
and see how it looks with the theming
but this allows you to change things
really quickly
all right so we'll close down that and
go back
into the slides you can also use
bs lib uh with our markdown now this is
somewhat experimental today
in terms of it is you know it's been
focused on shining i think that's really
what we want to talk about today is
shiny
but you can imagine that there are also
our markdown documents that have a shiny
runtime
or just our markdown documents you're
generating and you want to theme those
as well
so a one of the versions of our markdown
that should be merged soon
allows for theme arguments so you can
change again the background
the foreground the primary the base font
uh very similar to what you're doing
with your bs theme
argument in shiny proper if you don't
want to write out the whole theming
component yourself
you can again get access to all the boot
swatch themes so something like
solar you can pull that in automatically
by name
and while i'm really excited about kind
of the future of our markdown this is
still
more experimental in our markdown and
you'd have to install this
github version of our markdown to test
it out so maybe wait a little bit for
our markdown theming but
shiny theming is really going to be
ready in the next few days which is
very very exciting
um again for using some of the watch
themes for for shiny proper
um in the past this was through the
shiny themes package
so you would load like solar or darkly
or minty
all these different boots watch themes
which are listed here in terms of
there's a full list of i think
two or three dozen different themes you
could use um
this is just going to be loaded with
bootswatch and then and then naming it
within whatever fluid component you have
there are some newer themes from
bootswatch4 that weren't available
previously
um and so we are switching to you know
bootstrap four so if you wanted to use
an older theme you could look at older
themes but there's some newer ones as
well that are really really cool
awesome okay so uh we've kind of gone
over
a bunch of different things that are
themeable i'm going to turn over to
shannon here in a second to walk through
thematic which is the complimentary
package
to bslib but things that are currently
themeable and the next cran release
which again should be in the next few
days
the shiny package proper our markdown
html document
as long as you have that specific github
version dt
data tables which are perpetuated
through shiny and then really any
bootstrap compatible html and css
so you can add to this and add other
style sheets
that are bootstrap compatible some of
the other things that are soon to be
themeable and that the dev team is
working on and would love your help in
terms of open source contributions or
asks or different things that are
working on is some of the other html
based our markdown output formats so
beyond just html document
additionally a lot of the html widgets
have to be perpetuated through
so plotly will work through plotly but
in terms of plotline proper
reactable which is a package similar to
dt
for reactive tables and then some of the
other extension packages like shiny
widgets
that provide additional widgets that are
not in shiny proper
one of the things that's fundamentally
unthemable via css and therefore
bootstrap or
sas or bslib is plot output or
essentially r based graphics so blast gg
plot
base r those are images they're not
css in the classical sense where you can
change the components
they're generated by r um so the the way
to get around that is to use thematic
which actually translates the css
components
into these r plots so in this case
we'll use thematic to further extend the
theme from bslib
into things like plotting components i'm
about to be turning it over to shannon
and she's going to be walking through
the thematic portions
yeah thank you so once you've gotten
your
shiny application or our mark down
beautifully styled with
bslib one thing that you'll notice is
that the plots are not automatically
styling the way that uh tom just
mentions
and so that's where you're gonna wanna
use thematic because uh once you've
gotten that really nice
look to your shiny application you're
gonna wanna pass that on to your art
plots as well
so that's where thematic comes to the
rescue and what you can do
inside of shiny is use this function
thematic underscore shiny and you see
that we have that uh
bs theme set inside the shiny
application
and now that um setting is being passed
on
to the plots inside of our shiny
application so thematic is giving those
r plots the ability to
translate as tom mentions the custom
styling of the shiny application into
our styling and
and give that plot a very cohesive look
with the rest of the shiny application
so what the thematic package in general
does
is that it changes the defaults of the r
plots and you can use
that thematic underscore shiny function
to turn the customization to the plots
on inside shiny but you can also use
a function called thematic underscore on
to turn it on globally
and if you um do that you can also
within
that function set the specific
background
foreground and accent colors that you
want for the plots
so you can you know set the theming of
the plot there
and the other thing that you can do is
that you can actually set the font and
we have
set the font here to indie flower and
indie flower
is actually a google font um what
thematic does that's really cool
is that it will automatically download
cache and register with
r any google font that you want to use
inside your r plots
um the other thing that the mata can do
is in the slide before this
we customized the theme of each of the
plots but we can also
thematic will also just grab the auto
theming so it will detect
what the html container uh settings are
of the plot and it'll apply those to
your
r plot and what that looks like uh
inside of an rstudio session so if
you've turned thematic underscore on
if you've run that function and you're
in our studio
and you have a custom appearance or our
studio theme set
it's going to auto detect that rstudio
theme so you get this actually really
nice look inside your studio session
where the plot is actually
looking again cohesive with your our
studio session
um and then similarly it'll do that same
thing where it'll automatically detect
your
our markdown settings or your shiny
settings and so
if you have used bs underscore theme
and customized your shiny application
the
auto detection the auto theming inside
thematic
is going to be able to apply the
settings the
aesthetics that you've set for your
shiny application to
your plots
so why this matters um because it's
going to help you to create really
cohesive
beautiful arm markdown and shiny
applications
after you've spent all that time
customizing the look of your
applications if you're a markdown report
thematic is going to let you easily
apply those settings to your plots to
again make everything look really nice
and cohesive
you can still use traditional theme
settings inside ggplot for one-off plots
but what thematic will let you do is is
apply that to the whole document the
whole application or
to all of the plus that you're making in
our studio if you want to
and with that i'm going to hand it over
to tom who's going to show you some
thematic in action
perfect thank you so much yeah so as
shannon mentioned
you know you can use it with our
markdown you can use inside shiny
and then it will also work directly
within kind of just an interactive
session
so here i'm going to load the thematic
and ggplot libraries
um i will turn thematic on just as
shannon showed in the slide deck like
we're setting basically a theme
for everything in the session and then i
can just create a gg plot
so this is a very simple mt cars gg plot
that everyone's looking for and it will
you know perpetuate what i asked it to
here into the plotting panel in terms we
have that red theme
we have the white uh in black background
for me specifically i'm using the
dracula or studio theme so if i didn't
want to
perpetuate something forward i could
actually just
tell it to use whatever's in my
environment so in this case what's going
on in our studio
and the ide theme so i can create the
plot call the plot
and again it will kind of use
the pink and the dark purple and the
black and the gray that is made up of
the
rstudio ide theme i'm using
for bs lib and shiny you know the
bootstrap thing preview we did will also
show you a plot that automatically
themes the plotting portion because it's
calling thematic as well
for our markdown you know you we showed
that you could do thematic and bslib for
those
items proper so here i have
a theme component inside in our markdown
dock so it's an html document
and then i'm calling uh auto for
thematic here because it's going to
reflect whatever the bs
lib components are so if i knit this it
will actually go through
this is again just the basic d it's got
a
bass r plot a gg plot and then a summary
function
we'll let that build in the background
and i'll show you real quick what that
goes to
and we'll wrap things up
all right this over here
so again this is uh perpetuating all the
components into the r markdown so the
font is obviously
vastly different it's using kind of this
nice purple as the primary color
uh the base r has been reflected to
you know also be cohesive with the
overall theme
and gg plot as well so again this idea
of like you can theme shiny you can
theme plots you can theme our markdown
all by using similar syntax
um let me pull up the slides i'll just
rebuild
the beauty of our markdown slides is i
think i closed it down so i'll just i'll
just rebuild it real quick
and we'll we'll close it all up
get to slide 32
[Music]
all right get all the way to the end
here
all right so yeah thank you for hanging
out with us for the past in about
25-30 minutes um in summary you can use
bootstrap lid to theme shiny and our
markdown
this will upgrade to bootstrap 4 by
default if you're having apps breaking
you can always downgrade to version
equals 3.
you can use bootswatch or custom design
for your own custom themes
you can use bootstrap underscore theme
preview or bootstrap
underscore themer to quickly preview and
update themes interactively
there's a full-blown article about
theming with bs lib
a link here that we'll share in a second
and you can use thematic for easier
theming
of our plots in conjunction with
bootstrap labs so our markdown
base r g plot uh lattice all these
different components can be
you know perpetuated with the theming
through i'd really like to thank carson
sievert for letting us adapt part of his
slides
and thank you to absalon for bringing us
in today they're going to have a lot of
wonderful presentations about sas and
more theming
and their semantic package which is a
way of like
getting further away from what
traditional shiny apps look like into
really
really custom really really cool
applications and i will stop talking and
thanks for your time
you